[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département tout de suite
l'actualité en chiffres ils ont tous
obtenu le premier prix du concours
célimène juniors cette classe de 4e du
collège célimène gaudieux à la
saline-les-hauts a été récompensé pour
son oeuvre la femme mosaïque un tableau
aux multiples facettes qui représente la
femme réunionnaise dans toutes ses
expressions à me représenter la poche
d'autres formules
les malheurs eux
de tenir que ceux des femmes
des portraits premier voulait et on a
verbalisé sur ses papiers
ajouter des touches d'horreur chacun est
la risée la dernière
moi j'en ai eu
petit à petit on est tanné
vers 7 heures il y avait du conages sur
les agents de la collectivité
récompensés pour leurs années de service
envers la population réunionnaise pour
leur engagement
près de 300 agents ont reçu la médaille
d'honneur départementale de cérémonies
ont été organisées une à villèle pour
les agents de l'ouest et du sud et une
autre à la villa du département pour les
agents du nord et de l'est
pour moi c'est un grand plaisir mais
aussi un grand honneur que de remettre
cette médaille aux agents du département
j'ai souhaité nouer une relation
particulière avec des agents de la
collectivité parce que j'estime que nous
élus et les agents nous formons une
grande famille
chacun dans son métier il ya près de 200
métiers qui sont exercées par les agents
du dimanche dans ma qualité de président
j'ai le devoir de d'orienter mais aussi
d'un soufflé aussi ce sens du service
public et je le fais avec plaisir et
détermination c'est avec la commune de
saint pierre que le département signe la
première convention du pacte de
solidarité territoriale
un dispositif qui vise à accompagner le
développement des territoires à la fois
dans le domaine économique et social
le département met à disposition des 24
communes
une enveloppe de 90 millions d'euros
disponibles sur trois ans aller vers le
renfoncement de l'épanouissement evra
il faut avoir des équipements de qualité
dans les quartiers et à vous réalisez un
petit terrain de football où bien des
équipements comme une bibliothèque
wallon un centre d'animation un centre
d'accueil pour les gramounes là ce sont
des équipements de proximité qui sont
très utiles et qui favorise politique
l'épanouissement humain le lien social
mieux vivre ensemble et la promotion
l'épanouissement des hommes et des
femmes de la réunion
c'est cette belle ambition et nous
portons cette ambition avec les maires à
travers le pain de solidarité
territoriale
il y a deux cents ans et c'est le poète
réunionnais le coup de lille pour lui
rendre hommage ses collégiens ont
travaillé sur deux recueils de poèmes
édité par le département bestiaire
choisi et paysages choisi ils se sont
appropriés ces textes qui l'ont ensuite
restituée compter la lune tristement
baignent les noirs feuillage leur n
entend plus les mieux meilleur humain
sur les sables aux lois chante l'armée
est suivie d'effet des junos et des bas
comme j'aime bien les douze danseurs de
l'association el cph de sainte-marie
rentrer à la réunion avec une médaille
d'or et une médaille d'argent
ils ont remporté le prix de la
chorégraphie la plus festive au concours
national
andy dans sa bouche ça représente
beaucoup de travail
et beaucoup de pognon pour longtemps
volontariat c'est l'histoire de chacun
de nous donner tous quand on voit ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire capable de
réaliser
vous vous rendez pas compte une personne
en situation de handicap en fauteuil
roulant par exemple qui fait qu'ils
dansent qui fait danser son fauteuil
mais si jamais vue sans moi et ça là ça
nous donne un autre sens et on se dit
arrêtons de nous plaindre
le bonus de cette semaine c'est la
remise des prix aux 71 lauréats
collégiens et lycéens
récompensé par le concours défense et
illustration de la langue française
les prix ont été remis par l'association
des membres de l'ordre des palmes
académiques la réunion petites îles dans
l'océan indien
c'est quand même
[Applaudissements]
et donc celle qui défend la langue
française dans le sang un gain donc à
voir ce concours est de voir tous ces
jeunes récompensés
oui je dis c'est une fierté
[Musique]